[Musik]
wie die heiligen haben auch ihre
lieblinge ihren platz hier im kloster
es ist die hockey mannschaft der kloten
flyers
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich wird bei dem fleisch
nicht mehr wir hoffen dass er
zurückkommt einer dieser spinne hat
angerufen und gefragt ob er nicht für
die flyers beten könnten
seit nun mehr als zehn jahren beten
prior in dominica und ihre mitschwestern
dass die kloten flyers erfolgreich sind
wie die nonnen für göttlichen beistand
für die flyers bieten und gleichzeitig
irdische freude ernten davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
das benediktinerinnenkloster st johann
befindet sich in steyr ein kleines
bündnerischen dorf an der grenze zum
südtirol seit vielen jahren das zuhause
von prior in dominica
[Musik]
diese mauern sind nicht da um uns
einzuschließen sondern um uns zu
beschützen
diesen schutz brauchen wir um ein
zurückgezogenes leben führen zu können
das klosterleben gib mir das was ich
immer gesucht habe nämlich den lieben
gott und der so sagt bio in dominica
führt sie mit einer guten hand durchs
leben
es hat ein bisschen mehr als einem jahr
ist sie die neue priori will heißen die
oberin des klosters
seither sagt sie habe sich hier nicht
viel verändert ausgenommen eine
kleinigkeit
als ich in dieses priorat kam dachte ich
was mache ich bloß ohne computer deshalb
habe ich die gemeinschaft der nonnen
gefragt ob ich einen haben da dies
größere ausgaben sind entscheiden alle
gemeinsam
ich habe die erlaubnis bekommen prior in
dominica ist mit zwei schwestern und
einem bruder aufgewachsen der hier noch
nicht geboren war
getauft wurde sie auf den namen luigi
oder wie ihre mitschüler sie heute noch
nennen die nada thomas ihre kindheit
verbrachte sie nur wenige meter neben
dem kloster mit 25 jahren wagte sie den
schritt und traten benediktinerinnen
orden bei als nonne hat brio in dominica
auch 34 jahre den kindergarten des
dorfes geleitet kloten flyers und einer
der zu ihr in den kindergarten ging ist
marcos senna ich bin im style
aufgewachsen er ist der neffe von prior
in dominica meine dankte ist nonne und
er hat einen plan
eine überraschung für seine tante denn
marco weiss bescheid er kennt die
heimliche leidenschaft der benediktiner
nonnen des klosters sankt johann wieso
ist es so was ich mache das mache ich
recht all das aber nicht alles oder
nichts
darum geht es auch im mail welches
markus keller den flyers schreibt wir
nehmen die flyers in unsere gebete auf
nicht damit sie gewinnen
klar ist das auch schön aber in erster
linie wollen wir mal für menschen bieten
die nicht ganz zu uns nonnen passen
hier hingegen geht es ums gewinnen
ich hoffe sehr dass es funktioniert auch
wenn ich jetzt die zweifel die hoffnung
stirbt aber bekanntlich zuletzt
vom plan ihres neffen art prior in
dominica nichts
sie waren bis jetzt nicht den garten sie
waren in kreuzberg
also willkommen herstellung
der alltag der nonnen ist stark
strukturiert mal oder
ballaballa prior in dominica arbeitet
normalerweise im büro als prior ihn muss
sie aber auch auf das gemeinwohl ihre
elf mit schwestern achten wenn du bist
ja sie hat immer gute laune und wenn
etwas nicht in ordnung ist muss sie
einfach lachen nur das ist das beste
[Musik]
die neue steuer leben in einer klausur
das heißt in einem geschlossenen kloster
hier leben sie ein einfaches leben ein
leben ohne große einflüsse von außen ein
leben ohne fernsehen fast ohne fernsehen
ihr nicht nein aber in gäste teil hätten
wir einen und schaut ihr die spiele der
flyers die schauen wir uns im gäste teil
und das wäre nicht erlaubt
wir fragen schon um erlaubnis das heißt
jetzt fragen sie mich um erlaubnis vor
jahren wäre dies nicht denkbar gewesen
damals lebten die neuen völlig isoliert
sie produzierten alles was sie brauchten
selber dies ist auch heute zum teil noch
so jedoch die grenze zwischen klausur
und außenwelt existiert heute nicht mehr
zumindest optisch gesehen als marco der
neffe von prerow in dominica geboren war
gab es diese noch
ich war auf dieser seite des gitters
marco und seine mutter adelina auf der
anderen seite ich habe dieses niedliche
kind gesehen und hätte es so gerne in
den arm genommen
doch dieses dämliche gitter war im weg
ich hätte es weg reißen können
nach einer weile sagte ich zu adelina
dass wir mal wo sicher durch eines
dieser löcher bringen
und tatsächlich wir haben es dann
wirklich geschafft das baby hindurch zu
reichen
ich konnte es in den arm nehmen und ihm
einen kuss geben
das war ein wunderschöner moment dann
müsste ich mal wieder zurückgeben
darüber reden wir noch heute
ich kann mich gut daran erinnern als wir
sie besuchten war sie auf der einen und
wir auf der anderen seite das gibt dass
das war für mich ungewohnt denn im
kindergarten sah ich sie immer von
angesicht zu angesicht
hinter diesem gitter war sie wie im
gefängnis deswegen war ich manchmal
traurig auch wenn es das gitter nicht
mehr gibt die nonnen dürfen das kloster
nur verlassen wenn es wirklich nötig ist
und weil sie nicht hinaus dürfen hat
markus keller die flyers eingeladen die
nonnen im mister zu besuchen
das mail mit der anfrage an die flyers
hatte gesendet und wartet nun auf die
antwort
ja auch so ich bin skeptisch aber noch
immer guter hoffnung und bein sprang
sein muss schreibt denkmal ist wie der
ikarus ich weiß es noch nicht
aktualisieren das braucht bei diesen
computer einen augenblick bei guten tag
sg na das ist ja sehr interessant ja das
wäre sicher ein mal was neues auch für
unsere jungs spielen so ein klo kloster
zu besuchen will von den kloten flyers
werden bereits in der vorbereitungsphase
august bei der nonnen im kloster ist
teil des programms zu halten werden dann
bleibe ich finde die ihnen in kontakt
damit wir das weitere vorgehen
besprechen können
bis dahin wünsche ich ihnen einen guten
eine gute zeit und ich werde mich wieder
melden freundliche grüße andere
sensationell
[Musik]
die nonnen bis nichts davon dass sie
bald von den flyers besucht werden für
sie geht der alltag weiter wie immer vor
44 jahren hat brio in dominica sich
entschieden diesen weg zu beschreiten
es war ein langwieriger prozess
ich sah welchen weg meine freunde
beschritten
ich dachte mir ich könnte doch denselben
weg gehen aber ich merkte dass dies
nicht das richtige für mich ist
[Musik]
damals habe ich auch oft geträumt
es waren träume die mir sagten du
gehörst in eine gemeinschaft die ein
gemeinsames ziel verfolgt so habe ich
angefangen diese gemeinschaft zu suchen
ich kann nicht sofort auf die idee des
klosters vor dem kloster graute es mir
denn ich kannte es ein wenig ich wusste
wie das mit der gehorsamkeit war ja das
mit dem gehorsam war das schlimmste für
mich ich wollte frei sein und deswegen
habe ich mir das lange überlegt die
ungewissheit machte der traurigkeit
du mensch der bruder von prior in
dominica stürzt mit 14 jahren beim
spielen in eine schlucht und stirbt das
war nicht der moment in dem ich mich
entschieden ins kloster zu gehen
da dachte ich mir so lieber gott wenn du
so mit mir umgeht ist dann kannst du
mich ich hatte eine riesige wut auf gott
es dauerte lange bis sie gott verzeihen
konnte und ins kloster gehen
[Musik]
entschuldigen wenn ich dich während des
gebetes stören
um sicher zu sein dass seine tante auch
da ist wenn die kloten flyers kommen
sagte er nur dass er wieder einmal zu
besuch kommen möchte mit
überraschungsgästen keine ahnung und
ohne helm erkennt sie sowieso keinen
einzigen spieler
wir müssen denen vorher noch sagen dass
sie einen helm aufsetzen ist dann ist
der tag der überraschung da die erste
mannschaft der kloten flyers ist auf dem
weg ins münstertal und mittendrin marco
für die mannschaft die in der höchsten
schweizer liga spielt ein
außergewöhnliches ereignis
[Musik]
im gleichen moment im innenhof des
klosters in steyr nonnen kommt rüber auf
die wiese sie wissen immer noch nicht
was sie erwartet das gleiche gilt für
sie der papst vielleicht der könnte auch
mal hierher kommen es darf aber auch
eine weniger wichtige person als der
papst sein
vielleicht kommt eine klasse die früher
mal bei mir im kindergarten war heiko
lena vielleicht
also der papst ist nicht kommen
die sputnik marco den kenne ich ihn
kenne ich schon nicht mit marco was
machst du dir sachen erkennst du diese
leute schau genau hin
[Musik]
zwar sind große berge und wälder fanclub
panik bekommen
dennoch liebe das ist ein spiel mit
einem volley mit ihr sind mit november
also im bereich der weg am morgen
gemacht hat und cisco sind wir beten ja
schon lang und die kloten flyers und
2002 und retter benedikt da ich behaupte
amt gewählt maschine darf ich war und
sie stehe wohl leder schaftlich
leidenschaftlich gern für euch hört also
zum wohnen auch die flyer
ich bin ganz erstaunt dass sie den weg
auf sich genommen haben um zu schauen
was wir fans für wesen sind
[Musik]
ja die matte stehen und tabletten der
name christen ist cool und und schicke
76 meter musste damit er wieder 100
tagen darauf eine nachbarin der witz
gemacht also ja auch schloss dankern
mit dieser aktion haben die flyer sogar
denjenigen überzeugt er eigentlich fan
vom hc davos ist
ich bin doch sehr überrascht dass alles
so gut gegangen ist kloten hat auch ein
stück meines herzens erobert
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das hätte ich mir nicht träumen
so geht wie die nonnen von mister ein
sehr spezieller tag zu ende auch wenn
gerade ein taten dieser beweis dass die
benediktinerinnen von mister einen sinn
fürs weltliche haben die nachwuchssorgen
jedoch von prior in dominica bleiben
wir können keine werbung für dieses
leben machen man muss dafür berufen sein
wir können nichts anderes tun als
abzuwarten und zu hoffen dass die jungen
frauen sich dieser berufung bewusst
werden und dann auch hierher kommen und
wenn das nicht eintrifft dann müssen wir
die bude schließen
das habe ich schon mal gesagt
oder eben das vaterunser beten wie sie
es auch in zukunft für ihre flyers
machen werden
[Musik]